are you willing to put a stamp right now
on when the witness is going to be out
or you have a really no I mean the most
important thing is that it's a good game
of course and I've given a lot of
release windows and I work on one game
yeah for five years or something four or
five years and then after that it's it's
easy to feel like oh it's been so long I
just want to put this out there so
people can play it right but that's that
end of that development cycle is when it
most matters right because you don't get
a chance to make another game this good
for four or five more years maybe if you
can figure out how to make them faster
which I'm working on but you know like
if it takes four years to get back here
I don't want to waste that opportunity
so we're right doing everything we can
to make the game good it's really
stuffed full of interesting things like
I can't even communicate how much stuff
is in there and it's funny because you
watch the trailer and it's like oh I see
some beautiful environments and I see
like some lines on you know and it's
it's all gonna make sense later I just
can't yeah I mean I just can't say more
than that without starting to spoil
really really good things
it's the game life video podcast it
finally let us on YouTube bad idea